And the last time the rich guy invited us,
he also invited a couple of philosophers.
These guys were philosophers of mind.
Their specialty was the philosophy of consciousness.
And they were full of all kinds of jargon.
I'm trying to remember the words --
"monism," "dualism," categories all over the place.
I didn't know what those meant, neither did Dick or Sydney, for that matter.
And what did we talk about?
Well, what do you talk about when you talk about minds?
There's one obvious thing to talk about:
Can a machine become a mind?
Can you build a machine
that thinks like a human being that is conscious?
We sat around and talked about this -- we of course never resolved it.
But the trouble with the philosophers
is that they were philosophizing
when they should have been science-ophizing.
It's a scientific question, after all.
And this was a very, very dangerous thing to do
around Dick Feynman.
(Laughter)
Feynman let them have it -- both barrels, right between the eyes.
It was brutal; it was funny -- ooh, it was funny.
But it was really brutal.
He really popped their balloon.
But the amazing thing was -- Feynman had to leave a little early;
he wasn't feeling too well, so he left a little bit early.
And Sidney and I were left there with the two philosophers.
And the amazing thing is these guys were flying.
They were so happy.
They had met the great man;
they had been instructed by the great man;
they had an enormous amount of fun
having their faces shoved in the mud ...
And it was something special.
I realized there was something just extraordinary about Feynman,
even when he did what he did.
Dick -- he was my friend; I did call him Dick --
Dick and I had a little bit of a rapport.
I think it may have been a special rapport that he and I had.
We liked each other; we liked the same kind of things.
I also like the intellectual macho games.
Sometimes I would win, mostly he would win,
but we both enjoyed them.
And Dick became convinced at some point
that he and I had some kind of similarity of personality.
I don't think he was right.
I think the only point of similarity between us
is we both like to talk about ourselves.
But he was convinced of this.
And the man was incredibly curious.
And he wanted to understand what it was and why it was
that there was this funny connection.
And one day, we were walking.
We were in France, in Les Houches.
We were up in the mountains, 1976.
And Feynman said to me, "Leonardo ..."
The reason he called me "Leonardo" is because we were in Europe,
and he was practicing his French.
(Laughter)
And he said, "Leonardo,
were you closer to your mother or your father when you were a kid?"
I said, "Well, my real hero was my father.
He was a working man,
had a fifth-grade education.
He was a master mechanic, and he taught me how to use tools.
He taught me all sorts of things about mechanical things.
He even taught me the Pythagorean theorem.
He didn't call it the hypotenuse,
he called it the shortcut distance."
And Feynman's eyes just opened up.
He went off like a lightbulb.
And he said that he had had
basically exactly the same relationship with his father.
In fact, he had been convinced at one time
that to be a good physicist,
it was very important to have had that kind of relationship
with your father.
I apologize for the sexist conversation here,
but this is the way it really happened.
He said he had been absolutely convinced that this was necessary,
a necessary part of the growing up of a young physicist.
Being Dick, he, of course, wanted to check this.
He wanted to go out and do an experiment.
(Laughter)
Well, he did.
He went out and did an experiment.
He asked all his friends that he thought were good physicists,
"Was it your mom or your pop that influenced you?"
They were all men,
and to a man, every single one of them said,
"My mother."
(Laughter)
There went that theory, down the trash can of history.
But he was very excited that he had finally met somebody
who had the same experience with his father
as he had with his father.
And for some time, he was convinced this was the reason we got along so well.
I don't know. Maybe. Who knows?
But let me tell you a little bit about Feynman the physicist.
Feynman's style -- no, "style" is not the right word.
"Style" makes you think of the bow tie he might have worn,
or the suit he was wearing.
It's something much deeper than that,
but I can't think of another word for it.
Feynman's scientific style was always to look for the simplest,
most elementary solution to a problem that was possible.
If it wasn't possible, you had to use something fancier.
No doubt, part of this was his great joy and pleasure
in showing people that he could think more simply than they could.
But he also deeply believed, he truly believed,
that if you couldn't explain something simply,
you didn't understand it.
In the 1950s, people were trying to figure out
how superfluid helium worked.
There was a theory.
It was due to a Russian mathematical physicist.
It was a complicated theory;
I'll tell you what it was soon enough.
It was a terribly complicated theory,
full of very difficult integrals and formulas
and mathematics and so forth.
And it sort of worked, but it didn't work very well.
The only way it worked
is when the helium atoms were very, very far apart.
And unfortunately,
the helium atoms in liquid helium are right on top of each other.
Feynman decided, as a sort of amateur helium physicist,
that he would try to figure it out.
He had an idea, a very clear idea.
He would try to figure out
what the quantum wave function of this huge number of atoms looked like.
He would try to visualize it,
guided by a small number of simple principles.
The small number of simple principles were very, very simple.
The first one was that when helium atoms touch each other,
they repel.
The implication of that is that the wave function has to go to zero,
it has to vanish when the helium atoms touch each other.
The other fact is that in the ground state --
the lowest energy state of a quantum system --
the wave function is always very smooth;
it has the minimum number of wiggles.
So he sat down --
and I imagine he had nothing more
than a simple piece of paper and a pencil --
and he tried to write down, and did write down,
the simplest function that he could think of,
which had the boundary conditions
that the wave function vanish when things touch
and is smooth in between.
He wrote down a simple thing -- so simple, in fact,
that I suspect a really smart high-school student
who didn't even have calculus
could understand what he wrote down.
The thing was, that simple thing that he wrote down
explained everything that was known at the time about liquid helium,
and then some.
I've always wondered whether the professionals --
the real professional helium physicists --
were just a little bit embarrassed by this.
They had their super-powerful technique,
and they couldn't do as well.
Incidentally, I'll tell you what that super-powerful technique was.
It was the technique of Feynman diagrams.
(Laughter)
He did it again in 1968.
In 1968, in my own university -- I wasn't there at the time --
they were exploring the structure of the proton.
The proton is obviously made of a whole bunch of little particles;
this was more or less known.
And the way to analyze it was, of course, Feynman diagrams.
That's what Feynman diagrams were constructed for --
to understand particles.
The experiments that were going on were very simple:
you simply take the proton,
and you hit it really sharply with an electron.
This was the thing the Feynman diagrams were for.
The only problem was that Feynman diagrams are complicated.
They're difficult integrals.
If you could do all of them, you would have a very precise theory,
but you couldn't -- they were just too complicated.
People were trying to do them.
You could do a one-loop diagram. Don't worry about one loop.
One loop, two loops -- maybe you could do a three-loop diagram,
but beyond that, you couldn't do anything.
Feynman said, "Forget all of that.
Just think of the proton
as an assemblage, a swarm, of little particles."
He called them "partons."
He said, "Just think of it as a swarm of partons moving real fast."
Because they're moving real fast,
relativity says the internal motions go very slow.
The electron hits it suddenly --
it's like taking a very sudden snapshot of the proton.
What do you see?
You see a frozen bunch of partons.
They don't move,
and because they don't move during the course of the experiment,
you don't have to worry about how they're moving.
You don't have to worry about the forces between them.
You just get to think of it as a population of frozen partons."
This was the key to analyzing these experiments.
Extremely effective.
Somebody said the word "revolution" is a bad word.
I suppose it is, so I won't say "revolution,"
but it certainly evolved very, very deeply our understanding of the proton,
and of particles beyond that.
Well, I had some more that I was going to tell you
about my connection with Feynman,
what he was like,
but I see I have exactly half a minute.
So I think I'll just finish up by saying:
I actually don't think Feynman would have liked this event.
I think he would have said, "I don't need this."
But ...
(Laughter)
How should we honor Feynman?
How should we really honor Feynman?
I think the answer is we should honor Feynman
by getting as much baloney out of our own sandwiches
as we can.
Thank you.
(Applause)